effects because I I like sex at the end
of the day is spiritual unification I
feel like I've gone through a lot of
different stuff I've had a lot of
different experiences where I did not
value myself so I never had a man that
valued me so it's like yeah you rack up
guys and guys you shouldn't be texting
back or whatever but I feel like they're
I understand that there is a difference
with how men view sex and how they move
around in the world but it's like sex is
a sacred thing no matter male or female
is doing it so that's why for me like my
biggest like the hardest for me to
understand is like this is such a a
sacred thing and it's just being it's
like taking a piss for a guy can I just
say something you sure making love to
somebody about having sex
I'm sorry you were sure that you were
making love to somebody with that was
just having sex
no that's what it sounds like to me it
sounds like as women they make love to
men that are just having sex right
that's the difference that's not the
point where but my thing is okay so I
think when men hear that though it's
like if it was sacred to you you would
have waited till you were married but
it's like right no I get I get that but
the the reality is is that the world is
not so black and white so I understand
that there are these things in place
that worked and made sense and now we're
approaching an era that like we don't
know what's gonna happen but there's
gray area you've had sex I've had sex
she's had sex we've had sex with
different guys that doesn't mean that
we're damaged goes we're used Goods I
understand status is a big part of that
I understand that sex is view
differently but I feel like you should
not if you're if you're looking at face
value I can understand why you would be
judged from your past but if if I'm a
guy interested in you I don't care about
what you've done
like men do though that's the thing like
like a virgin's more valuable to a man
than a girl that's had sex with multiple
men like it just is what it is there's a
limit the modern man he's not a virgin a
modern man needs a partner somebody
that's actually some smart and surviving
the men with the most Choice they're
going to pick women that are more pure
in general the ones that already
self-made I guess so but that's the
thing the reality is the reality is that
there's a lot of men out there
especially in the world that we live in
today that need a partner so it's time
for those masses of men to start
respecting women for the role they can
play in their lives I don't think I
don't think average men expect women
but is this rhetoric that actually then
is pumped into these mines and creates
what people not complain about the
misogynistic world that's what it is
Independent Schools
misogynistic for men to prefer women
that are more it's not that it's but
it's not that's not the problem the
problem is now listen the maths is very
simple you've got people like Andrew
Tate talking about these things with
such Clarity and it makes so much sense
because it is true right and then you
have men that are in these situations
where just average working an average
job and they cannot fulfill whatever
definition is called to be a man in
these yes they can and that's not what
they said he didn't say that yes they
can nine to five man can do it but then
again but wait wait this is the thing
what we're talking about as a man and
this is why I say it's very important
for us to understand the person that
we're speaking to and I'm very glad that
you clarified everything that you mean
not every man is like Andrew Tate not
every man is going to be able to even
realistically demand for certain things
from a woman so the same way women need
to compromise if he comes to a man who
is going to cheat on her because he's a
top G it's the same way men are gonna
have to compromise and stop blabbing
about purity
and you didn't get none of them I made
my point that was the whole point
because
I made my point
is that too many women they see regular
guys and they feel they're settling
you're not settling you're getting what
you deserve but you can't be asking
questions
but the difference is men know this like
most average men the average men
wait wait wait the difference is average
men no they don't deserve a 10. they
know they don't deserve an eight they
know they don't even deserve a seven and
they still go messaging them on the
stores and all this dumb stuff that's
just ugly most men in history haven't
even reproduced and so it's like man no
but we the women are the ones that are
delusional's worth there's regular men
out there that will that will have you
down but can I just say people are
watching not understanding that Tate is
part of that one percent of uh and they
think that they can demand the same
thing
one second one second one second sorry
sorry I understand the point you're all
making but let's understand something
to the sexual Marketplace females have
always been and still to a degree are
The Gatekeepers it's men will you can
think about it in a very simplistic way
this is not the case but let's simplify
it for the sake of argument imagine men
will run around and [ __ ] anything
and women are the ones who say yes or no
you are The Gatekeepers that have all
the power and this is what's actually
truly interesting about the sexual
Marketplace because whenever women go
there's not enough good men then why are
you [ __ ] of course why would they be
good if you don't make them be good
you're a [ __ ] losers
so women so you're talking about I'm
saying that you know the man a certain
level can't do certain things if you
were with Joe schmoe and he wasn't
treating you the way you believe Joe
Schmo should treat you then why you
wouldn't believe like do women women
have the gatekeeping so if you get Josh
Moe and he treats you like you're you're
his Queen treats you perfect good if you
get a [ __ ] guy at the absolute upper
echelon's value and and you still don't
aren't happy with what he's giving you
then leave women are The Gatekeepers you
women actually have all of the Power
this is what's beautiful to about the
whole thing women are constantly
complaining you have have all the power
you're the ones who get to choose do you
know who you should be mad at for all
this [ __ ] I'll tell you you should be
mad at do you know who threw away all
the female power in the sexual
Marketplace promiscuous females because
now you got chicks who will bang anybody
without trying so why should a dude get
up and try no do you have any idea how
hard it is to actually be let me make
this clear do you have any idea how hard
it is to actually be no [ __ ] a man
and I say this and women go oh yeah dude
as soon as most women encounter any kind
of problem the first thing you do is
turn to a man their man their dad the
mechanic the police a man if you
actually put a woman from a problem and
go no men they're like oh sh whoa [ __ ]
it's a mental breakdown men day after
day especially if you're a high level
man let me make it something clear from
my life I'll talk from personal
experience I'm not just looking after me
I'm not just looking after my chick I'm
the guy and about 300 people's phone
books that they call when anything big
goes wrong you get arrested in Russia
extraction from Ukraine you need a
million dollars whatever it is
Kazakhstan abduction they call me I'm
the first phone call I'm fixing 400
different lives I'm a Problem Solver
chicks can't fix [ __ ] any of this
[ __ ] right this is how hard it is to be
a man and it's amazing because Society
expects it of you but so do women
if you had a man be honest you had a man
and you went to your man and said oh
I've got this problem it's I can't fix
this it's broken the car Tire's broken
and he went I don't know
you would dry up like you'd be like well
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] point are you
that's the truth you could sit here and
go all we'd call a mechanic no you
wouldn't you'd look at your man go what
do you mean you can't fix it
yeah and this is what she's saying about
your man will get up and go and you know
what's beautiful about masculinity a
bunch of times a man will go up and he
doesn't have a clue how to fix himself
but he'll go don't worry baby okay and
he'll stand up with no money and no clue
and he'll go out there and [ __ ] try
and find a way because there's a man you
need to be useful it is so difficult to
be a man you have no idea the amount of
pressure that we're under from society
and from the women we even want to
associate with on a whole is difficult
just to keep all these things in mind
it's hard
you see what you just said about yeah
the top gee that if that money you can
fly planes and fly that
drop it down to if you were earning like
say 50 000 a year yeah couldn't you be
that same person amongst your peers 100
that's what I'm trying to say 100 good
and also also you have to money doesn't
make you a top G no no money's an
amplifier so that's that's the first
thing about money money amplifies men
can make money money does not make men
if you're a dork and you get rich you're
a rich dork if you're a gene you get
rich you're a top G right so that's the
first thing about money and I agree with
you but traditionally and this is the
Baseline and once again when I say these
things I'm not looking to be attacked
from your misogynist I'm just commenting
on how I view the world and how I see
things traditionally a man primarily
gives his attention to a female to get
sex and she gives him sex back to get
the attention that's the swap right so
if I'm a dude and I want sex from a girl
I give her attention I talk to her I
hang out with her I spend time with her
eventually I get the sex that's how it
works but the higher value you are as a
man the more valuable your attention is
the more valuable your time is the less
you have to give it's like potency right
so I can give five minutes to a chick
and that's worth two weeks of some other
dude's time but that's the reality so
where you are on the scale is just
basically how much of your time you have
to give now you can still give all your
time to a woman treat her like a queen
be respected by your peers she can be
happy with you I'm not saying she will
be any in fact I'll argue she'll be
happier with that man than she'll be
with a [ __ ] guy like me I'm not even
out here someone make chicks happy I'm
not even saying that I'm saying that
she'll get the amount of time that she's
gonna want from that man the amount of
attention is linked to his status but at
a true high level status of man it's two
DMS 10 seconds 10 seconds
this kind of leads into my next question
all right guys let's take second to hear
from our Channel sponsor for